- [Kelly] This is so cute!
- Thank you.
- I literally just bought
something today with mushrooms on it.
I don't know, it was like a mug.
And I was like, "Why am
I into mushrooms lately?"
What did you say?
- Everything is mushrooms,
I know.
- Yeah. That is insane.
- They say it's good for your brain,
but I'm like, "Nah! When
you get to be sixties,
there's not a mushroom."
- There's not a--
- There's not.
- I don't know.
I think that's why I saw this
fantastic fungus or fungi
or something on Netflix.
- Yes.
- Yeah, I saw that.
Maybe that's subconsciously.
That's how they get you.
And now I'm buying everything mushrooms.
- You can eat them and you can wear them.
- Yeah. But they're really good for you.
- Yes! They're very good for you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, they're very good for you.
I didn't know that.
So how are your kids, both of your kids?
How are yours doing?
- They're awesome.
- Yeah.
- I can't stand it.
My oldest turned 15
and got his driver's permit the other day.
- [Kelly] Are you nervous about it?
- I'm not.
- Are you nervous about him
or drivers?
I'm nervous about drivers.
- I'm more nervous about drivers
'cause he's been driving a while.
I mean, we have a farm
and he also drives the
car up the driveway.
- Oh! My kids drive our little
like Kenny and stuff like that too.
So I think it's good prep.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But so I'm not worried about him,
but the texting thing, you know.
I was like, "Lemme get him a
great big stick shift thing
so he can't like do this,"
but I don't think he will.
I think he's--
- Yeah.
Oh! I know how to drive a stick
but I refuse to have one
as a regular vehicle.
- Yeah. I grew up driving it.
- It's a lot.
- Yeah. I'm already like ADHD.
So I'm like, "Oh, I tell a lot going on."
Are they musical like you?
- They are.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- My 12 year old is more into to sports
but he can play piano.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then Wyatt who's older plays piano,
but he's an amazing bass player.
- Oh really?
- You'll love this.
He said, "Mom, when I get to be 18
I wanna be the bass player in your band."
I'm just like (sobbing).
- What!
- You won't wanna play with me
but I love that you think that.
- Oh my God! That's so nice.
- I know. Isn't that cool?
- But to be on stage, like very
few artists get that moment
with their kids that end
up in the same field.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you ever worry?
Are you, I mean,
we're excited for whatever they wanna do,
but do you worry about them
being in the entertainment industry?
- I don't. I mean,
they're both leaning towards
things that are bigger
than music, the music industry.
Like Wyatt is more into the environment
and wants to work on reefs
and has always done that.
And then Levi is deciding
between the NBA and the NFL.
He's not sure which one
he is gonna go into yet.
- He said, "You know what,
which one do I wanna pick?"
- He's gonna weigh his options.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah.
- So wait, I didn't know this,
but you started out as a music teacher.
- I did.
- I had no clue.
Was it elementary?
Is that what it was?
- Kindergarten through six
in the St. Louis Public School System.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- Yes.
- So is this so you could,
I imagine this is a day job.
Then on the weekends you did, you gigged?
- I did. I was in a cover band
and then I got in a
band as a backup singer.
And then I started getting commercials,
like a guy walked in who was a producer
and hired me to sing on
a McDonald's commercial,
which paid me twice what I'd
made in two years of teaching.
- Which is such a statement for teachers.
I know it is, it is.
It's like sometimes I look
at paychecks and I'm like,
"Gosh! My mom worked so hard."
- Yes. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, in the end I started
getting more commercial work
and I went to LA and thought,
" I'll get a record
deal and become famous."
- Like so many, like in your life.
It happened though, thank you.
'Cause it worked out for us too
that got to learn.
- It was all overnight too.
- It was?
No, I hate when they do that.
- I know.
- Even for me I'm like,
"You don't think I worked
before I was on there?"
I was like, "But okay, sure."
And even if it was, it's
the longevity that counts.
It starts staying there.
But you and your family
recently had an estate sale
which I think is awesome
'cause my sister just had a garage sale.
- [Amy] Okay.
- So in estate sale,
- It's the same thing.
- It's like a fancy,
it's a fancy garage sale.
My sister was like so excited.
We love garage sales.
We didn't never venture to estate sales
'cause we didn't have the
money if we were kids.
But like, but is that what it is?
It's like a fancy garage sale?
I've never been to an estate sale.
- You know what it is?
It's like, well I'm a
massive collector of crap.
So if you guys were online,
saw what I was selling,
I have a lot of the art.
- [Kelly] I think there's
a word for that; Hoarder.
- Yes. My sister says that the
difference between hoarding
and collecting are aisles.
(Kelly laughing)
So I'm sort of more of a,
I'm gonna be torn
somewhere in between that.
- Well I wanna show, this
is some of your stuff.
So do you have a
fascination of creepy dolls?
- Don't judge me, don't judge me.
- What is the creepy doll thing?
I just need to know.
- I don't know.
I think if there are past lives,
I'd have a few questions for myself.
I don't.
I mean, yeah, I don't even
know how to explain it.
- [Kelly] But I actually would've
wanted that little number.
Like the tribal thing, that's cool.
Like hanging on the brick wall?
That's cool.
- [Amy] Yeah.
I mean, well, and the surfboard.
- [Kelly] No I don't surf.
- Yeah.
I got that when I turned 40
and I learned to surf so I'm
gonna sign it an autograph.
- I just turned 40 and I will
not be learning how to surf.
(Kelly and Amy laughing)
- I will not.
- Were you ever terrified
of like sharks or anything?
- No, no. And 40 was my best year.
40 is gonna be your best year.
- 40 is already my best.
It's been days and it's
already my best year.
- Yeah, It's your best three days in 40.
- [Kelly] Yeah, It's my best moment.
No, it literally, I think
life gets exponentially
the older you get.
As you get wiser,
hopefully some of us don't.
- Yes, yeah.
When you get to be my age,
you're gonna be really wise.
- No, it's like, no I do.
I feel like life does get better.
It gets simpler and you realize like,
no isn't a crappy thing to say to someone.
It's actually just setting a boundary.
It's nice, I've been to therapy.
- I love that, I love that.
'Cause it took me getting
breast cancer to learn,
"Okay, sometimes you have to say no
as an exercise."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You cannot make everybody happy.
You can't say yes to everything.
- What is it with artists?
Why do we, we're people pleaser.
- It's like in women.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So yeah.
- Her new Showtime documentary
is called "Sheryl".
So what was it like to
look back at your life
and your career and this documentary,
was kind of scary or weird?
- I think for me,
obviously I have like 30
years of my own career
and then I had a whole life before that.
I think people forget,
especially with social media and stuff
that we're people.
- Yeah.
- And that behind the artistry
and the drive to be an artist,
there's a world of challenges in there
that made you want to reveal
your your vulnerabilities
and write music.
And we're really quick to
judge and quick, you know?
So when Showtime came to me and said,
" Do you wanna do documentary?"
I was like, "Absolutely not."
- Yeah.
- And then I kind of warmed up to the idea
of telling the story about the person
as opposed to the person
that wrote "All I wanna do"
and "Suck up the sun" and--
- 'Cause those are
different chapters of us.
- They are, and your big hits
don't necessarily represent who you are.
They give you an opportunity to go
out into the world and play your songs.
But it's the deep cuts
that really tell the story.
So it's been an interesting
thing and I hope people
when they watch it feel
inspired and they feel like,
"Oh! Okay, yeah.
I've gone through depression
or I've had sexual harassment in my life
or I'm getting old and what
does that mean in my career?"
You know, that kind of thing.
- Yeah.
- There's all kinds of
challenges that we all go through
whether you're famous or you're not.
So, and that's what it's about.
- I agree.
Was there anything,
because this happens to me sometimes.
It's only 20 years for me,
but I just mean it happens to where
somebody will say
something and I'll be like,
"Oh my God!"
Was there anything like in the documentary
that you were like you surprised you
like about yourself or like what happened
or you didn't remember?
Okay. I wanna know what's happening.
(Amy laughing)
Okay. I wanna know, I wanna know.
I wanna know, don't lie.
I wanna know what's happening right now.
- This is total vanity.
I mean, it's so stupid.
- I'm so excited.
- First lemme just press it
by saying that my kids say,
"Mom, you know you were
born in the 1870s."
(Kelly laughs)
- All our kids think we're old.
- I know and when I watched it I was like,
"Oh my God! I'm so old."
- But I mean they redesigned.
- No. I do see pictures
and I'm like, "Oh!"
For me, I'm like, I see pictures
I'm like, "Oh my God."
- Like, you're not.
- I don't even care.
- But that's the thing,
- Like that's so good lucky.
- I don't usually care but
when you're watching yourself
like on a camera speaking, you're like,
"Oh my God! My mouth is so ugly."
Or then, "Why am I making
that facial expression,"
you know mouth people.
- You're known for your mouth.
People love your mouth.
- Oh that's very nice.
- Like that's that's so funny.
- You do?
- You're like known for it.
Did you know?
- Oh my God! I love that.
- No, but you're known.
That's like one of your things.
So see, this is why, okay.
So I don't watch,
- You can't watch yourself.
- I don't watch myself.
I don't watch interviews,
I don't watch any,
I don't watch myself.
I don't or any articles
that people review,
anything like that.
- [Amy] Good.
- Because I think it changes you.
And I think the things
that people love about you,
you'll change them and
that's what people love.
So do you do that?
Do you read anything?
- I don't.
Since my second record, I've
not read one single thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't want people to tell me.
I like being there, feel good about it
and then I don't want
somebody to rob me of that
by telling me that it wasn't good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And sometimes I'll be like,
"That wasn't very good."
But I'll own that.
I just don't want somebody else
telling me their opinion, you know?
(Kelly laughs)
- Stay on your own front porch, sir.
- Yeah, who are you, exactly.
Who asked you?
So, I love that with this,
this was so smart because as a super fan,
like you also released
a greatest hits, right?
With the documentary?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] With "Sheryl".
So like what, tell us about that.
- So there's, there's obviously,
the catalog is filled
with songs that are from,
that everybody knows.
And then there's some
songs that were featured
in the documentary and there
then there's three new songs.
And what was kind of
interesting about the new songs?
Well, first and foremost,
there's a cover of "Rolling Stone"
song called "Live with me"
which is featured in the documentary.
It's the first time I ever got to sing
with "The Rolling Stones".
- Wow!
- And I was super nervous.
But we recut it and then I thought,
"I'm just gonna text Sir. Mick Jagger.
I have his phone number, Oh my God!"
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- And asked him if he
played some harmonica on it
and he's like, "Yeah."
And so I sent it
and so he's on it.
- Wow!
- And then I don't ever put
my kids in social media.
I never have.
- Yeah.
- And they're actually
featured in the video
called "Forever".
And I wrote it really for my kids
just 'cause our kids now are so stressed
and they have big things they live with.
I mean, we're in a war.
Are we gonna lose somebody
that we love to a pandemic?
I mean, there's all these.
- And just growing up.
- Not to mention being a teenager.
- Those are hard times.
- And social media.
And so I wrote a song called "Forever"
and they're featured in
that and they're just,
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Rashes.
- And one day he's gonna
play bass with you,
it's my favorite part.
- One day he's gonna play bass
with me.
- Oh! Like that would kill.
I would cry.
- I just feel certain,
by the time he gets to be old
enough to be in his own band
that being in his mom's band
is probably not gonna be
like a cool thing.
- I think he's gonna be rad
and he can do both.
He can do both.
- Yeah. Maybe.
- Yeah. I'm just saying
- He's probably gonna ask
me though right off the bat
like what he's gonna make,
you know what I mean,
like, "What's my salary?"
- But you know what,
you've raised him right.
- That's right.
- "I know my worth, mom."
- That's right, business man.
- So wait, so your
lyrics, they're very pure.
They're very raw and honest.
That's what I gravitated
towards and still do.
So what's your writing process?
Like it's always different for all of us.
Like I have to be completely alone.
Like what's yours?
- Yeah. Well I went through
years where it was like
I gotta be tortured,
I have to have at least seven
or eight bottles of wine
by myself.
(Kelly laughs)
And then I can only have between
11 and six in the morning.
And after breast cancer,
I felt like I had this
three-month-old baby.
I brought him home the second he was born.
And the world looked
different to me, you know?
And I found that I could write,
if I could just sit down quietly
and I'm a big meditator as well.
If I could just like--
- You're good at that?
I need to be good at that.
- Well, it's a practice.
- I know.
- It's not a perfect,
it's a practice.
- I know, okay.
- And that's so cliche.
But yeah, I mean that helps too.
So I just find that creativity is not,
you can't just schedule it in,
but you can be awake and enough
to get outta your own way.
Sometimes I craft a song
'cause I know how to do it.
Other times, something just,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like the song "Forever" I go,
"Where did that come from?"
- That's my favorite
time when you're like,
"Okay, so I was just purely
the vessel for that."
- [Amy] Yes.
- Like I love that moment
and it just flows outta you.
- You're just like, "Thank you."
- And you can't believe you did something,
you're like "Cool."
- Yes, yeah.
- 'Cause most of the
time it's not like that.
It's rare I feel like from, maybe not you.
- Show up and you're like, "No, it is."
I made a record called "Be myself"
and we made it in three
weeks and I was so inspired,
worked with my buddy Jeff
and we made it between school
drop off and school pickup.
And it was the most
fun record I ever made.
- Oh my God! That should
have been the title.
- Nobody bought it and nobody heard it,
- That should have been the title.
- But it was so great.
- "School drop off, School pickup".
- Yes! That's exactly.
"Drop off, pickup".